quelle année pour le cinéma français
comme je dis toujours il vaut mieux
réussir la cérémonie que réussir à céret
monique et le césar du meilleur
réalisateur est attribué comme tous les
ans à jacou mondiaux noah jacques
audiard dieu qu'est ce qu'il ya comme
aguerris mais toi c'est revenez dans son
principe après coup de faire l'amour
tout le temps comme ça que je pense
doucement doucement tous les os côte me
rouiller très haut niveau demande si ça
serait pas mieux de redémarrer par la
piscine 14
il paraît qu'il ya la môme qui donne des
cours j'ai envie de lui demander
on avait un exposé est prévue pour
aujourd'hui féminin et puis on vous
écoutera nous et puis j'ai rien préparé
de tout temps les acteurs et les
actrices aussi françaises se sont
intéressés à travailler le commentaire à
la maison que je vous l'avez demandé
non j'avais piscine monsieur c'est sûr
avec quel modèle marion cotillard vous
n'avez pas plutôt passer votre temps à
écrire votre journal intime à copier vos
malheurs depuis sa liste
eric à l'encré bleu des mers du sud mais
disons laspalès tu as changé de ton là
avec les méthodes de vieux pervers il ya
une actrice française qui va finir par
jeter par la fenêtre
tabou aussi personnage il voit je veux
le monde et j'ai vu des sabres que tu
m'a choisi pour la cérémonie sur de toi
parce que moi j'imagine les plus une
arrivée à la brûler quelques costards a
dit 1000 boul il est où le rêve la nuit
debout quand même
wen interdite créer du rêve de la
surprise à temps complet alors du coup
je pourrais peut-être laissé mon costume
d'homme biwetz ont mis cher non parce
que ça ce serait ébranlée ça va
avec
bon eh voilà des voix fait que c'est au
mans comme tout elle je savais que
j'allais dire ça voilà c'est trop lui
qui dit c'est ça et moi les mecs je rêve
d'avoir un look comme vous la côte et
les moustaches les couettes le côté un
peu biker bombail curling est d'accord
mais biker pour aller on va aller dans
la forêt exercices de base comment bien
taper sur l'europe et sur les roumains
mais les gars vous n'êtes pas au con
c'est qu'on a changé de président quand
même ouais terre le nouveau il veut
taxer à 75%
c'est à dire bon je vous laisse vous
promener entre mecs dans la forêt mois
pendant une semaine j'ai passé là bas
knicks et je retourne dans ma piaule
chercher des petites idées comics et
qu'est ce que tu fous là nom m'est égal
je suis à une valérie lemercier et non
moss ont peaufiné mon numéro de mains à
chaque regard derrière pearson numéro de
ouf avec une figure je te raconte même
partir d'un petit je te fais
à quai
oh
amman
oui
gibbs
super
je le devais
toutefois m
à
m